I say to all the people of Northern
Ireland that we want a storm that is
based on firm foundations to do that we
need to remove the rubble of the
protocol that has undermined our economy
that has inhibited our ability to trade
within our own country that has changed
our constitutional status without our
consent a protocol that every day is
harming businesses and driving up the
cost of living for every single person
in Northern I will not rest until this
matter is resolved and the sooner that
happens the better
well as the debate began the first
Minister designates chin fein's Michelle
O'Neill was highly critical of both dup
and the Tory government
Jeffrey Donaldson and the dup are in a
Perpetual standoff with the public the
majority of whom they do not speak for
or indeed represent
he stood for election yet failed to show
up
this is his mass and a failure of
leadership by him and his party
Jeffrey Donaldson and the dup have left
us all at the mercy of the heartless and
dysfunctional Tory government whose own
Survival is all that ever counts the
Tories careless for the consequences of
their dire policy decisions and their
political choices on the lives of
workers and families here
Jeffrey Donaldson points the finger at
everyone else for the dup's own
indefensible and enduring failures
well let's just show you the scene live
now inside Stormont as politicians have
gathered this lunch time we are going to
bring you all the updates from Stormont
as we get them first so let's reflect on
how we arrived at this point and
Northern Ireland has had a parish
sharing government between Nationalist
and unionist political parties it was
created in 1998 following the signing of
the Good Friday agreement now this
helped to end over 30 years of violent
conflict known as the troubles but after
19 years stormwater collapsed in January
2017 when Shin Fein ended power sharing
over the Democratic unionist party's
handling of a green energy scheme for
three years storment was in a freeze
with progress on many important issues
stalled in January 2020 a deal was
drafted to restore Northern Ireland's
government both parties accepted the
deal Paving the way for power sharing to
be restored
but by February 2022 the dup's first
Minister Paul Gibbon resigned in protest
at the Northern Ireland protocol while
Stormont didn't completely collapse at
this point it's only been functioning in
a limited capacity
well our senior Island correspondent
David Blevins has been following events
at storm on this lunchtime so David tell
us what we've heard and where this
leaves the Northern Ireland assembly
foreign
you've given us the timeline to this
point over the last 25 years arguably
let me give you the brief timeline going
forward if the Northern Ireland assembly
has failed to form a government by
midnight tonight then ministers who've
been there in a kind of Shadow form
since the assembly was dissolved for the
election six months ago cease to hold
office at which point the Civil Service
effectively steps in to govern Northern
Ireland and for many people that is a
disaster in the middle of a cost of
living crisis the fact that there would
be no ministers in place also at one
minute past midnight the Northern
Ireland secretary Chris Hayton Harris is
legally obliged to signal that we're
going back to the polls a 6.5 million
pound election probably taking place
before Christmas and many people find
that astonishing considering that if
there is no agreement on how a
government will be formed we could very
well find ourselves back in exactly the
same position after an Assembly election
and if that happens then we really will
be in Uncharted Territory because the
British and Irish governments would
probably have to return to the
negotiating table 25 years after the
Good Friday agreement to try and devise
some kind of new form of governance that
might just work for Northern Ireland and
of course this trail of difficulty can
be traced right back to brexit because
brexit posed a greater challenge to
Northern Ireland than any other part of
the UK because of its land border with
the Republic the dup championed brexit
But ultimately it resulted in the
Northern Ireland protocol that was the
Compromise Boris Johnson struck with the
EU he established a trade Border in the
Irish sea instead between Northern
Ireland and the rest of the United
Kingdom to avoid a need for a tangible
border on this island the dup say that
is not acceptable it treats Northern
Ireland differently to any other part of
the United Kingdom and until it's gone
they say they're not prepared to return
to the power sharing government and all
of that means that Northern Ireland
really is without a functioning
administration at the height of a cost
of living crisis